[Music]
winston moss assistant head coach of the
green bay packers at least until last
night have been mentioned from time to
time as a potential head coaching
candidate he gets interviews from time
to time and maybe he was trying to make
a case for himself to be the successor
to mike mccarthy he had an idea on
tuesday morning to post a tweet and the
tweet reads as follows ponder this what
championship teams have our great
leadership period it's not the offensive
guru trend it's not the safe trend find
somebody who's going to hold number 12
that's aaron rodgers and everybody in
this building to a hashtag lombardi
standard period
losing sucks well losing may suck
winston but i have a feeling getting
fired sucks even more that's what
happened to winston it's nothing funny
about it
although it is i don't know is it funny
it's kind of i mean there's some i mean
look it's comical from the packers
perspective that they would react to
something like this by parting ways with
winston moss i don't have any problem
with what he said no like why would you
fire the guy over this are you that
sensitive that's not going to get you
the best possible outcome to this
coaching search if you're going to be
that sensitive i i agree i mean i guess
it's he's overstepping his boundaries
and we've talked about this a million
times the nfl is very militaristic as
far as pecking order do your job we
don't need you making statements for the
team i mean that's the way it is you
wouldn't see this go on in new england i
mean that's where we're going to hold
the standard right you want to talk
about winning culture well winning
culture doesn't have assistant coaches
tweeting out thoughts about the team so
now his tweet is right i give him that
but it's also not part of championship
culture for you to be tweeting out as a
coach so it's a double whammy his tweet
is correct 100
i mean any great franchise throughout
history it is just a team i mean that's
why we always hear in new england you
free agents go in there and tom brady
gets yelled at just as much as the free
agent guy that got signed off the street
last week that is what great winning
football teams do i got a theory i got a
theory right i think winston moss made
his views known over and over again
within the walls of the organization and
this was his last desperate act to make
sure people understand
that real change is needed in green bay
but a compelling situation but clearly
moss moving on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports